i love the idea of normalizing um the
topic of abortion and reproductive
rights i had to really
stay true to the situation this isn't a
movie about
hand-wringing what decision to make she
knows what she wants and that's
very much how i felt um about my
abortion you always use a condom so
you're fine
hey dude i want to talk about how it's
obviously a really
light-hearted movie with comedy and
feel-good moments but at the core of it
there's
really serious subject matter so i want
to know how important
was it to you to get that story right
because it
is light-hearted in a way but like for
me i was
i couldn't ever take veronica and her
situation lightheartedly so it was hard
and a challenge to be in these scenes
where everything's going wrong and
things are comedic and over the top and
there's this teen comedy tone over the
whole thing this like quirky tone but
like i had to really
stay true to the situation i think um
there's there's a balance where things
can get either a little too goofy or a
little too
um uh over dramatic about what's
actually happening
not true to the characters i love the
idea of normalizing
um the topic of abortion and
reproductive rights and
also telling a different perspective on
it and how
uh people should don't have to feel a
certain way after getting an abortion
there's a whole range of spectrum of
emotions that happen
the plot of the movie sort of inherently
has
the message that i think is important
which is that it should not be this hard
to access abortion
and so the fact that innate to the plot
is this crazy journey they have to take
and that's where so much of the comedy
comes from is
how hard the journey is sort of uh was
really helpful in telling this story
i don't think that this is what you
really want it's my life it's my choice
i took a tour of the los angeles planned
parenthood
um i've had an abortion but i had the
pill abortion and i was unfamiliar
with the um the process for the surgical
abortion so i got to go in and see step
by step
how you know what all the steps were and
i learned so much
that as i was there i was inspired to
sort of reimagine that sequence and
and show people demystify the process
i just want to say thank you for for
sharing something that's so
personal and so you know your story and
your story alone
um did making this movie um
did it trigger anything was it difficult
in that respect because you could relate
no one thing that i love about this
movie is how sure veronica is of what
her choices from the beginning that this
isn't a movie about
hand-wringing what decision to make she
knows what she wants and that's
very much how i felt um about my
abortion
the whole scene when she actually gets
the abortion
in the clinic i was experiencing that
whole
couple days that we were filming that
sequence through veronica so i was
feeling all of the nerves
and then the um you know just like not
knowing what to expect
finally being there it's finally
happening the mixture of like the weight
and then the relief and um i was just
experiencing all those feelings through
her um and it just felt really real i'm
curious what kinds of conversations you
had with haley was that a closed
set was it a really intimate experience
a couple of the vignettes were closed
out we had a wonderful
um uh nurse who has
who is involved in um er abortions
that was with us the entire time and so
she was helping us
just making sure that we were medically
um you know doing the right things and
everything looked right but you know i
mean we we took it
seriously and and haley you know haley
uh is always bringing truth to her
character so she was bringing
truth to the moment i appreciate
everything you've done for me
you're a crazy idiot that is so goddamn
nice let's go one of my favorite moments
in the movie is during the carnival
scene
and you and haley lou are on the ride
and you're screaming
i'm gay and i'm pregnant
i'm curious if you and your life barbie
if you've ever had that kind of
like an epiphany aha moment where you
just
let something go and started to like own
it and celebrate it
oh my god all the time being a model and
being a bigger girl that was the first
step for me
and then kind of navigating um uh
the media and having people really
interested in me even at a young age
um and kind of hyper critical i kind of
had to really empower myself
by um accepting who i am and also being
pretty like abrupt about it and not
really apologizing for it and
um just kind of just doing what my gut
tells me to do
rather than what other people think i
should do i kind of have those cathartic
moments like i'll go down to the beach
sometimes and just like scream
my deepest darkest secrets or
insecurities or wants from the universe
or whatever
but honestly i feel like i get a lot of
my
pent up energy or whatever out through
characters that i play
um and then i think that like in turn
makes me kind of more crazy as a human
being because i feel so comfortable
doing that kind of stuff as an actor
that then in my life i'm just
equally as loud and crazy being able to
physically like
scream or being able to just like say
out loud the things that you keep inside
you i feel like is a very important
thing for people to do
regularly
you